Can Muhammad be in contradiction to the
message of Jesus who came before him?
>> I'll say it again to you. It's Allah
who's confirming the previous prophets.
Muhammad never makes such a claim.
That's it. No. Muhammad doesn't have to
follow the teachings of Jesus.
>> So, yes, he can contradict what Jesus
taught.
>> Yes.
It's got [music and singing]
the
>> All right. So, first before we get into
this, man, number one, I want to ask
you, have you seen all the drama that's
been going on, bro?
>> I don't do drama, mate.
>> That's good. You haven't seen the the
stuff with me and hijab?
>> Um, yeah, the copyright thing. Yeah.
Yeah, I have seen it.
>> Yeah. You've never copyright struck me
when I've come to your lives and like
posted this stuff on my on my channel.
I've never had to ask you that.
>> Yeah.
>> You think it's weird?
>> People are different. I don't know.
People are people, man. People do what
people do. I'm not bothering.
>> That's true. All right. Well, I'll tell
you why I believe. Oh, go ahead.
>> Before you do it, let's clarify
something else. The last time I was on
your mute and kick me.
>> Did I mute and kick you eventually? Yes.
[laughter]
>> Come here. Wait, why' you What was that
for?
>> Cuz people think I ran away. People
think I left. People think I'm the one
who left the stream when I didn't. But
anyway,
>> you wanted to get kicked. That's you.
Like, you made me do that on purpose.
>> I wanted to get kicked rather than
explain myself. You muted me, so I
couldn't speak. And then you kicked me.
>> That's cuz you were talking over me and
you wouldn't let me talk and I was
trying to answer you and you wouldn't
you wouldn't even even engage, bro.
>> No. You You brought out a red herring
that had nothing to do with the
conversation. You think you thought
there was nothing?
>> It's not true. How
>> would you like to run it again? Let's
Let's run it again. No problem. Okay.
So, my question to you was, was it
problematic if Paul was teaching
something that different to the
disciples of Jesus? Yeah.
>> Yeah. You said you cuz we were comparing
Paul and Muhammad and you were saying
that what makes Paul a liar is that he
contradicted the teachings of Jesus and
the apostles. So then I asked you I
asked you, okay, so whoever contradicts
the teachings of Paul's and the uh I'm
sorry, the apostles and Jesus that
they're a false messenger. You said yes
and then I asked. Okay, cool. So, did
Muhammad was Muhammad in line with the
apostles in Jesus? And that's when you
evaded the question.
>> No, that's why you muted me.
>> No.
>> Okay. So, I'll respond now. It's not a
problem. Okay. So, if somebody claims to
be following the teachings of Jesus.
Yeah. Like Paul was claiming it and the
disciples of Jesus obviously were
claiming it, but the prophet Muhammad
sallallam wasn't claiming that.
>> Yes, he was.
>> Okay. So, he wasn't. Where where does
the prophet claim to follow the
teachings of Jesus?
>> He he says that he came confirming the
teaching of Jesus and that he was upon
the same religion as the prophets before
him.
>> Where did he say that he's being told
what to say undo by Jesus?
>> Well, that's that's not the that's not
what this is limited to. If he's saying
that he's look look if he's saying that
he is confirming the message of Jesus,
that means that he cannot be
contradictory to the message of Jesus.
Wouldn't you agree?
>> No. No. No. That's not what he's doing.
And that's not what he's saying.
>> Okay. The Muhammad peace never ever
claimed to be following the teachings of
Jesus. He could confirm well Allah
should I say confirms that Jesus before
him was a messenger sent by him. But it
nowhere does Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him make the claim
he's receiving information from Jesus.
He's receiving revelation from Jesus.
But Paul makes that claim. Okay? And so
>> Uhhuh.
>> So Muhammad doesn't make that claim. So
then you can't bring into a conversation
with regards following the teachings of
Jesus because Muhammad never claimed to.
>> I disagree. So if you are if you are in
confirmation, if when the Quran says
that it is in confirmation, it's a
confirmation of the scriptures that came
before and of Jesus. No, no, this is
this is this is relevant. Hamza, let me
let me tell you why it's relevant. Okay?
Yes, please let me just tell you why
it's relevant. If he's saying that he is
coming confirming the message of Jesus,
can he be in any way contradictory to
the message of Jesus?
>> Okay, understand something. The
teachings of Jesus was different to the
teachings of Moses.
>> Was it contradictory
>> to the teachings of Abraham?
>> Okay. It's that each had their own
Sharia. See, what you're doing is trying
to do an internal critique on my
position. Yeah. From our position,
Muhammad never made the claim he's
following the teachings of Jesus. Paul
made the claim. So, why didn't you
address the claim I said? Why do you If
Paul is not following the teachings of
Jesus, then he's unreliable based upon
the teachings of the disciples. Yes or
no? If he's not
>> No, Hamza. No. To answer your question
straight away. No. I disagree with you
right here. But Hamza, you you didn't
you didn't you didn't answer. I'm about
I'm about to tell you. You didn't answer
what I just asked you. Okay. I asked you
if the Quran is saying because I know
you believe it's from my law, but you
know Muhammad is the one reciting that.
If Muhammad is claiming to be a confir
No, it's not. If Muhammad's claiming to
be a confirmation of the previous
scriptures, can he in any way be
contradictory to the to the teachings of
Jesus?
>> I I'll say it. I'll say it again. Allah
is the one who's confirming what came
before. Allah is the one who's
confirming is also
say it again to you. Muhammad never
makes the claim he's following the
teachings of Jesus. Never.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. He never claim he's receive One
second. One second. He never makes the
claim he that he receives revelation
from Jesus. Never. Okay. Paul does Paul
does make this claim that he's receiving
revelation that he saw him on the road
to Damascus and then for 10 years
received revelation from Jesus. So he's
making this claim. The disciples of
Jesus who walk with Jesus of course make
the claim they're following the
teachings of Jesus. So if there's a
contradiction between those two people
who are both making the same claim
that's why it makes it problematic.
Muhammad doesn't follow the teachings of
Jesus never claimed to.
>> Okay. So Paul making the claim that he
follows the teachings of Jesus. If he
contradicts the teachings of Jesus he
would be false. I agree with that. Now
you I need you to answer what I'm asking
you. If Muhammad Hamza, notice how
you're cutting me off, dude. Come on,
man. You got to let me get it out.
>> I just answered you.
>> No, you No, you didn't. You did not
answer. All you did was say, "Well, you
know, he never made the claim that he's
following the teachings of Jesus, so
this is not applying." That's not what I
asked you. I'm saying
>> to you.
>> No, no, no. Don't say that again. Let me
just ask my question again, please.
>> Question.
>> Okay. So, my question is when Mua So,
you're saying it's Allah. I don't
obviously I don't believe that Muhammad
is the the the pro No worries. Muhammad
is the prophet of Islam and he's making
the claim that he's coming confirming
the message of the prophets before him.
So my question is can Muhammad be in
contradictory contradiction to the
message of Jesus who came before him.
>> I'll say it again to you. It's Allah
who's confirming the previous prophets.
Muhammad never makes such a claim.
That's it. No. Muhammad doesn't have to
follow the teachings of Jesus. So yes,
he can contradict what Jesus taught.
>> Yes. Did Did Jesus teach the Hajj? Did
Jesus teach the Hajj? It's a
contradiction.
>> That's not a contradiction. That's not
contradictory. What I'm what I'm saying
is
>> What are you talking about?
>> Yeah. So the message of Jesus
>> the message that Jesus
>> I'll let you go ahead.
>> Anyway,
>> the message that Yeah. The message that
Jesus preaches preaches, can Muhammad
contradict it?
>> Listen, I responded. Okay.
You didn't respond.
>> Okay, now respond to Paul teaching
something different to the disciples of
Jesus.
>> No, you didn't respond. We're We're
holding that. Look, this is not going to
be unbalanced scales. I look, I agree
with you. Look, hear me out. I agree
with you. I look listen, let me get it
out. I agree with you that if Paul
contradicted the message of Jesus and
the apostles, then Paul would be a false
teacher. And so that's what I'm And hold
on a second because that's that's only
that's only one side of the coin.
>> The other side of the coin.
>> Well, hold on because this is what you
said. You said that anyone who
contradicts the message of Jesus and the
apostles is a false messenger. That
would go with Muhammad, too.
>> No, it wouldn't.
>> So So Muhammad can contradict Jesus and
be a true messenger?
>> Okay, I'll say it again to you. Does
Muhammad claim to be following the
teachings of Jesus like Paul? He claim
Yes. He He not Not not Look, I can I can
grant you that not in their way, but he
does claim to be still to still follow
the message of the prophets that he's in
line with them.
>> He He doesn't say he's following the
teachings of Jesus.
>> If he says that,
>> okay, if he says that he is confirming
the message of the of Jesus, does that
mean that he's in line with what Jesus
taught?
>> You keep acting like it's Muhammad
writing the Quran. Allah can talk about
the previous revelations and the
previous uh prophets. Okay. The point
here is this. The point here is this.
Muhammad doesn't make the claim that
what he's telling you is Jesus what
Jesus told him to say. Muhammad isn't
doing that.
>> Do you do you all is
>> but that's not you're still not
answering the question.
>> Can if when Ma can you can you agree can
you agree that Muhammad makes the claim
to be a prophet of Allah?
>> Please please forget this. Okay. Let's
just tell answer the question. [gasps]
>> Uh see that's for the question that's
here.
>> All right.
>> Why do So, why do you believe
Christianity is true? Let's just roll
with it.
>> Sure. Sure. I I'll let you I'll let you
I'll let you off the hook on this one
because this was bad.
>> Don't let me off no hook, mate.
>> You let me off.
>> I did. I let you off the hook, man. You
got to thank me. No,
>> you didn't. [laughter]
>> Okay. U Why do I believe that
Christianity is true? Um I I believe
that Christianity is true. Uh one of the
big reasons for me is prophecy
fulfilled. Um, so I love Isaiah 53 and
how it predicts what happened to Jesus
on the cross. Um, and I think that that
is undeniable and irrefutable. So
prophecy with Isaiah 53 describing what
happens to Jesus I believe is uh
demonstrates that Christianity is true.
>> So the prophecy, how does that u
Christianity is true?
>> Well, you you would agree that prophecy
would be revelation of God, right?
>> How does that prove Jesus resurrected?
because it talks about his resurrection
in Isaiah 53 prophesies it says that his
days will be prolonged after he died.
>> He said he see his children mate.
>> Yes. He will see seed his his children
phys uh his metaphorical children
spiritual children.
>> Since when does that word refer to
spiritual children?
>> And if you go to Isaiah 57 verse4 it
talks about uh children of deceit. And
so obviously that's that's children like
deceit doesn't have literal kids.
>> No but when it's when it's talking about
a human being having children.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it could be it could be it
could be metaphorical or physical
>> according to the Jews. Okay. Why do you
believe your understanding of Isaiah is
is correct rather than the Jewish
understanding of Isaiah?
>> Because it's fulfilled prophecy and
their their understanding, you know, if
it depends on who you ask it. If you're
asking early Jews like the in the
Tarums, the Tarum like Tarum Jonathan
says that it's about the Messiah. So
>> what about Israel?
>> No, Tarum Jonathan. Tarum Jonathan says
that it's about so tar the tarams are
like second temple uh Jewish
interpretation of the scriptures and so
in the tar in taram jonathan on Isaiah
on the suffering servant passage it says
it's about the messiah
>> if I speak to any Jew they'll say the
suffering servants Israel
>> that's not true if you speak to a
messianic Jew they'll say that the
suffering servant is the messiah
>> okay if they speak to singer he'll tell
you that it's um Israel if you speak to
Josh the Jew from speaker's corner he'll
tell you that every Jew I've ever asked
about this question as to who is what is
referred to in Isaiah 53 they always say
is uh Israel.
>> Yeah, they're wrong because if you ask
if you ask if you ask if you ask radar
apologetics Eduardo he's a messianic
rabbi he'd tell you that it's about um
it's about the Messiah.
>> So so it's not necessarily concrete is
it differences of opinion with
>> not really what you're wrong.
>> No no so like Hamza that's like me
saying if I if I go to a Quran only
Muslim and say should I should does the
Quran teach to follow the hadith?
They'll obviously say no but you ask
Sunnis they'll say no. Oh yeah, the
Quran clearly says go to the hadith. So
that well like would that mean that
that's not definitive? You wouldn't say
that.
>> Okay. So Isaiah 53 is the reason you're
a Christian. You believe Jesus died for
your sins and such. Yeah.
>> Yeah. The the the the prophetic
revelation behind it. So meaning God
actually spoke and revealed this and it
happened. And so that's why um you know
demonstrates that Christianity is true.
>> Why do you believe Jesus? Why do you
believe Jesus had to be crucified?
>> Well, because that's what God said he
would do. God said in Isaiah 53 that he
will uh he will crush the suffering
servant, his Messiah, and for the sins
of of the people.
>> Okay. So, basically what you're saying
is God had to do this to forgive sins.
>> What I'm saying is that this was God's
plan. this what what I'm saying is that
this was God's plan to have an ultimate
sacrifice to forgive all sins that all
are a have an access to eternal life.
And so the fact that Isaiah 53
prophesizes this, the fact that this is
revelation
>> um shows that this is true. Wouldn't you
agree?
Well, if you want to like take from that
your interpretation that you choose to
understand it as and then you go to the
gospels and you read what happens there.
Where do you get this idea that it's the
final atonement for sin and and why why
is blood necessary
>> to for that's
>> no why is why is blood necessary to
forgive sin? Well, that that's a
different question. Like, so f first cuz
wait, hold on. Cuz cuz you're kind of
you're kind of dismissing what I'm
saying because you're saying there's
other interpretations that disagree with
no look no look. I look I can't Look, if
you're saying that's how you understand
Isaiah 53.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. That's how you understand it.
Okay. So, so now I'm trying to conclude
it to understand. So, you you you see a
prophecy, you go to the Gospels, you see
what Paul says or whatever it may be.
>> Yeah. [clears throat] and you come to
the conclusion that Jesus was the final
sacrifice. So, well, is that the end of
animal sacrifice or what what does it
mean?
>> Well, so if you're trying to conclude,
so you would you agree that I have a a
good reason to believe in Christianity
since this is a this is a prophecy about
the Messiah.
>> I'm pretty sure someone could argue
against you on Isaiah 53. I'm pretty
sure.
>> With what? With what arguments?
>> I don't know. Let's see. One second. I
think Corora is here. She might be able
to answer.
>> Oh, Corora.
>> Cora
was about. [laughter]
>> Yeah, she might. They deal more in in
this type of thing than I.
>> Okay. So, would you say that I have a at
least at least from where you stand now,
does it look like I at least have a good
case if if this is prophecy and it's
looking like it's about Jesus that, you
know, uh, Christianity is true?
>> I don't I I don't I don't uh because I
think the the the Gospels is full of
self-fulfilling prophecy. So I I I feel
that the authors of the gospels have
manipulated history to look like it's
fulfilling something that may have been
prophesized. So
>> but why but on on what like why like
what is what is your evidence for that
case?
>> Okay. Um there's many cases. Let's say
um
>> this one specifically
>> King Herod King Herod killing the babies
in Bethlehem for example.
>> No, but I'm talking about specifically
this specifically Isaiah 53. Like how
how is it that they're matching these
details on purpose to like how are
>> No, no, no.
>> No, no.
What I'm saying to you is if there's
evidence of the authors of the gospels
um manipulating
the the text to act like prophecies
being fulfilled and manipulating history
to behave like prophecy has been
fulfilled, then it's problematic to
listen to
to to trust what they're saying is
reliable or not. Because as soon as your
authors of your gospels have been shown
and demonstrated that they will lie and
invent history and that they will uh
manipulate prophecy to try to fit this
invented history,
>> you've got a problem with prophecy. I
would disagree because like let's let's
let's even grant this this uh assertion
that the gospel writers um have
manipulated details to seem like it's
matching um uh prophecy of old. How
would you how would that follow that in
this case that's what they did?
>> No. No. Once we because we can't trust
the gospel writers then
>> it's not true
>> because like I it's true. Of course it's
true. If if you can't if if it's not
reliable, the author is not reliable to
to uh recall history correctly and to
use prophecy correctly, it's very easy
to see what's been prophesized, create
some kind of fake history, and then say,
"Yeah, look, it fulfilled it." Yeah,
this is self-fulfilling prophecy. Okay.
Once you realize the authors of gospels
are doing that, you got a problem.
>> Yeah. So again, if even if I were to
grant the assertion that there are a
couple times that the authors have done
this, that doesn't follow that this was
this case. You have to prove that. And
so
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah. So you're saying you're saying
that uh if the uh gospel authors uh lied
in one place, that means that they're
liars in all cases. That's or you got
reason to believe that. I like it it
it's like this, you know, I'm pretty
sure you heard of Huff's uh the Huff's
argument before, right? how he's known
to be a liar with hadith, but you guys
trust him with the Quran. Does would
that mean that you can't trust his
recitation of the Quran since he was a
liar?
>> Okay. Okay, I'll say it again. If the
authors of the Gospels are creating
false history to fake fulfilled prophecy
is problematic. Just
>> you got to be consistent is what I'm
saying. Would you would you reject
Hoff's reading reading of the Quran
since he's known to be a liar
>> of hadith? So,
>> you got this habit of just throwing your
things under the bus to try to attack
Islam. I'm relaxing
your position.
>> I don't think that this is an issue.
>> You the Christians need So you don't
think it's an issue. The authors of the
gospels are not reliable. That's not
problem for you.
>> No, I'm saying you're wrong about this,
but with your assertion, you have to be
consistent.
No. Yes. What I'm what I'm saying is
what I'm saying is Hamza is that even if
I were to grant you this false assertion
that the apostles doctorred up uh
details to make it look like a prophecy,
you would have to come on. You got
please let me land.
>> You're going you're going to have to
show that this was the case here with
Isaiah 53. But you're saying, "Oh, well,
if they've done it elsewhere, then that
means that they're not trustworthy
anywhere." So would you have that same
thinking when it comes to Hoffs who was
known to be untrustworthy with hadith
but you trust him with the most recited
version of the Quran the Huffs Quran.
Would you have that same consistency?
>> Right. I never said the apostles were
the ones who lied and invented. I said
the authors of the gospels. I'm pretty
sure you don't believe the authors of
the gospels were apostles, do you?
>> Yes, I do. And so what I believe Matthew
was an apostle. I believe John was an
apostle. I believe that the the the
gospels are apostolic.
>> So, so the the the apostles that are or
let's even go with gospel authors.
You're saying that these authors are are
untrustworthy in certain areas. So,
therefore, we can't trust them when
they're recording the the crucifixion
event. And it matches exactly up with
what Isaiah 53 says. So, I'm saying if
you're gonna be consistent, would you
then throw away would you throw away
Hoff's recitation of the Quran because
he's known to be a liar?
>> Look, look, don't worry about Islam.
So, if the gospels, if the authors of
the Gospels were um like I said,
manufacturing history to create
prophecy. Yeah, I've already had a
conversation with you. You concede that
the well, you didn't really concede, but
the the Bible is corrupt. You You
believe that, don't you? The New
Testament is correct, obviously.
>> You know, I don't.
>> You
>> know, I don't.
>> No, you don't believe the New Testament
is corrupt.
>> No, I don't. Which is which is which is
a why one of the evidences that it's not
corrupt is the is the fulfilled prophecy
of Isaiah 53.
>> Why are you trying you're trying to get
away from this, man?
>> No, no, no, no, no. Let's understand
something. You don't believe the New
Testament is corrupt?
>> How many times I got to say it? I don't
believe the New Testament is corrupt.
Muhammad didn't believe the New
Testament is corrupt. No.
>> Why do you How do you understand the
word corruption of a text?
>> You're switching the subject, Hamza.
>> No, no, I'm on point here. Why? Because
you've you've I you've I premised it
that believing that the the New
Testament, the Gospels are not reliable
as um the they've been corrupted. What
you have today has been corrupted from
its original source potentially. Yeah,
>> that's that's that's fine and all. Well,
you're denying that.
>> So, you're denying that?
>> Of course. But that's another red
herring.
>> Okay. Well, let's Well, let's evidence
that. Yeah.
>> No, not right now. That's not the topic.
>> Okay. The authors of the Gospels were
not disciples of Jesus. Mark wasn't a
disciple of Jesus. He wasn't an
eyewitness.
>> Okay, fine. Who cares? The point is is
that they record the crucifixion event
that matches exactly what Isaiah 53
prophesied. What is your response to
that? Yeah,
>> I'll I'll say it again to you. You don't
care whether or not the authors of the
gospels are inventing history and
creating self-fulfilling impressions.
>> Prove it. Prove that they invented this
history about with in regards to Isaiah
53.
>> It's only your interpretation of Isaiah
>> Prove that alone based upon
>> just evidencing. If the authors of the
gospels are manipulating the text, yeah,
we're just evidence. This is what we're
evidencing. Pro. You only know what
happened at the crucif you only know
what happened at the crucifixion because
the authors of the gospels tell you
they're not reliable. How could you know
what happened?
>> Okay. Prove that the gospel authors
uh uh uh made up this story that just so
happens to match up exactly with Isaiah
53. Prove that they do that to match
that. What's your evidence?
>> Okay, I'll say it again. So, you accept
that the authors of the Gospels were
doing that? Yeah. [laughter]
>> No.
>> Well, okay. I demonstrate Wait, wait,
let me ask you this.
>> I demonstrate that.
>> No. Cuz I I I I do not care about red
herrings. I care about this that what
I'm talking about.
>> Let me ask you this. Would you Do you
agree that at least on a surface level
reading that when you look at Isaiah 53
that it matches up with the crucifixion
event of Jesus in the gospel accounts?
Do you believe Jesus was ugly that no
one wants to?
>> It doesn't say he wasn't. It doesn't say
he was ugly, but it it does say that he
wasn't special to look at. He wasn't
special to look at.
>> Well, Isaiah 53.
>> Yeah, he wasn't special to look at. He
had no he had no appearance that we
should desire him.
>> So what?
>> One second. One second.
>> Uh who has believed our message?
So let's see why the Jews believe this
is Israel.
>> I don't care.
>> Who has believed our message? And to
whom has the arm of the Lord?
>> Uhhuh.
>> Yeah. Keep keep going. Sorry. Keep
going.
>> Okay. Okay. To whom has the arm of the
Lord been revealed? He grow before him
like a tender shoot, like a root out of
dry ground. He had no beauty or majesty
to attract to him. Nothing in his
appearance that we should desire him. He
was despised and rejected by mankind. A
man of suffering and familiar with pain
like one whom people hide their fats. He
was despised and we held him in low
esteem.
>> Who's God talking about? She's talking
about the Messiah. And this is Isaiah
speaking, by the way.
>> Yeah. So, God is speaking through the
prophet, isn't he?
>> Well, Isaiah, it's it's a revelation
that Isaiah received from God. Sure. But
it's not like the verbatim speech of God
necessarily, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not.
>> No, it's just it's a revelation that God
gave to Isaiah.
>> He was he was oppressed and afflicted.
He didn't open his mouth. This is the
part you like, isn't it? He was led like
a lamb to the slaughter and the sheep of
which sheers as we know his mouth by
oppression and judgment he was taken
away. Yet who of his generation
protested. Okay. A few for he was cut
off from the land of the living. For the
transgression of my people he was
punished.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
>> See to my people is Israel. Israel is
being saved.
>> Is right. He was assigned a grave with
the wicked. Was he?
>> Yes.
>> Assigned a grave with the wicked.
>> Yeah. He was crucified with uh two
thieves and died a criminal's death.
>> Well, no. He died a according to what
you believe. Yes, my
>> sister. I am
>> so um he was he was what? A a thie's
death.
>> Uh he he died a criminal's death. He
died a a dying being crucified is a
criminal's death. And he was crucified
with two thieves.
>> One second. No, that's not what that's
not who you didn't have to be a criminal
to be crucified. Well, according to the
Roman,
>> it's a criminal's death.
>> The Roman
>> Okay. A criminal is not not somebody who
breaks the law, is it? In the Well, the
Romans, they crucified traitors. Yeah.
Yeah. Crucifi
would be breaking the law. That's
treason.
>> No, we be rebelling against Caesar,
>> right? That's a that's a that's breaking
the law. That's a that's a criminal.
That's a crime.
>> So, anyway, listen.
So he's he was assigned a grave with the
wicked, but he wasn't.
>> Yes, he was.
>> And with the rich and with the rich in
his death. Though he had done no
violence, nor has any deceit in his
mouth.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. It was the Lord want to crush him
and cause him to suffer. And though the
Lord makes his life an offering for sin,
he will see his offspring. He will see
his offspring and prolong his days.
>> You see how he will see his offspring,
meaning he will see those who followed
him and his days will be prolonged after
he was crushed.
>> No, no, no, no, no. That's what you're
saying. That's what you're saying.
>> That's what it says.
>> Well, no, the word doesn't say that.
>> It's same same price. You just
>> just swap it over. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I'll be honest. I've not really done an
isog Jesus or exesus on this particular
passage. So,
>> sure.
>> Um,
>> but we we Can you see where I'm coming
from, though? At least.
>> I'm doing I'm doing it as we go. Um,
>> yeah. I don't I don't mind us reading
through this and like breaking it down
and showing you why I believe this, you
know.
>> No, no, no, no. I I I would have to go
away to break this down to understand
it.
>> Why?
>> Um
>> why could you why can't we do it here?
>> Because I don't do things on the fly and
I don't do ad hoc response either, which
I'm feel like I'm being pushed into ad
hoc response and I hate ad hoc response
from anyone. So the last thing I'm going
to do is ad hoc it,
>> right? No. So what I'm saying is I'm not
I'm not I'm not trying to push you or
challenge you necessarily on this, but I
would I don't I don't mind going through
it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Look, look, the thing with
me, I don't roll this way. If if I've
not done an exodus or really looked into
it, um then I don't start giving you and
you're bringing this as your evidence.
So, this is your reason.
>> Yes.
>> For believing that this is referring to
One second. I think Liiano's here
because I know he knows this.
>> I I don't talk to him.
>> Would you mind if Liiano?
>> I I definitely Yeah. I don't I don't
talk to him. He's blacklisted from from
me. He He cursed my wife, slander my
wife on the internet. I don't talk to
guys like that and I think that you
would understand if a guy is going on
the internet slandering your wife and
doing all that kind of stuff. Yeah. No.
>> Okay. So, well, no disrespect. Your your
people who follow you are flipping
animals, mate.
>> I'm not going to That's fine. That's
That's different from going on
slandering someone's
>> life.
Yeah. Anyway, actually, I'm thinking Do
you want to debate me on Paul? The
reliability of Paul? I think we should
do it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm down for that. When you
want to
>> I've been considering it. thinking
>> cuz I was going to write my book first
and I'm thinking maybe debating you on
it will help me write the book.
>> Sure. Yeah. Um we could just let me know
man when you want to schedule it
>> and we can prepare and
>> uh do you have a particular platform
that you want to do it on? Does it
matter?
>> D
you can you can stream it to your
platform. I have it on my platform. It
doesn't really matter. We'll get a
moderator.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And um I'll get a fair moderator.
It's no problem. And like I say, you can
stream it. I can stream it. It's not a
problem.
>> Cool. [snorts]
>> See, here's the thing. You see, see what
people in the chat don't realize. Like
they think I'm running from this. No,
it's not how I roll. I like to ex
understand things. Yeah. But the debate
about Paul. Yeah, definitely. I think we
should make that happen because I think
without Paul there is no Christianity.
So, we just work out the title. That's
all.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh, hit me up and we'll talk
about it for sure. I'm down for that.
>> All right. All right. Peace.
>> Take care.
Free.